Kris Jenner Don's a platinum blonde wig
that has us saying Tori Spelling is that
you oh that's wild
[Music]
on Tuesday the kardashian-jenner family
matriarch was photographed outside of
Toys R Us in Los Angeles rocking blonde
tresses as she got into a silly-string
fight with her pal Jonathan Cheban it's
not funny
the 61 year old mom of six rocked some
blue shades a bold red lip and a
bedazzled denim jacket with a black
shirt and black pants as cameras world's
four Keeping Up with the Kardashians is
it just us or could Jenner fases the
Beverly Hills 90210 star's long-lost
twin niece per usual there's a lot going
on for the famous family there's so much
that goes on with this many members of
one family that you know there there's
always something that that happens on
Monday the momager tweeted this pic with
daughters Kim Kourtney Khloe and Kendall
as well as her grandkids rain and north
and Olympic ice skater Nancy Kerrigan
the reality star wrote quote oh no big
deal just ice skating with Pat Nancy
Kerrigan in Calabasas in 95-degree heat
for our Christmas special
[Music]
I